I remember being really angry like I
remember I saw red that's the only time
my whole life where I've been so angry
me I was like I'm never talking to this
guy we're just going to end all this we
treat things as materialistic objects so
this if I don't like this I'm gonna
drink this if I don't like this I'm
gonna replace I'm gonna say I'm not
having this again yeah yeah so now what
happens this is mentality we carry it's
a friendship and marriages yet you would
cut yourself you will cut your arm it's
for example let's say you cut yourself
and we'll join the blood together will
be conquered they stuck with blood
brothers
and you can thought you would change one
thing about me my wife enjoy all of your
favorites from gif toes Lahore karahi in
the comfort of your home with just a
click or a call that's not all we now
offer free delivery for all orders over
100 pounds delivery available within a
ten-mile radius with a 5 pound minimum
charge for the first 5 miles and an
additional 1 pound 50 per mile
thereafter enjoy a good day with a great
meal at gift days hope you guys are well
inshallah
so welcome to my Channel today I have
mousou after a very very long time so
this video is called why we found out
we're gonna be talking about a lot of
times not just once so we're gonna be
talking about that and if anyone's under
the misconception that with all that
time we only do videos and now we have
will clarify that as well so what we
want to talk about bomb sisters is
friendship and Brotherhood they say
blood is thicker than water
well we say Iman is thicker than blood
so you have water blood and Iman yeah so
we're going to talk about them in
gradual steps and talk about as Muslims
like sister to a practicing or not
practicing
but the thing is what does Brotherhood
and sisterhood really mean and how we
really understood that and we're gonna
be telling you guys inshallah our
personal experiences with each other as
friends because it's a real-life example
that would be in France for about seven
years so there's something we can talk
like we just you know so we'll just get
married and rock here and the media
video giving you an a/c on how to have a
successful marriage
yeah okay so this is something that's
this is a relationship that's been going
on for about seven years with all kinds
of rollercoasters ups and downs and
gunshots not literally have you fired
from hamdullah a good yes half a meter
distance I think is supposed to be two
years I guess this is good enough
yeah exactly so let's talk about let's
talk about how our friendships died okay
yes I think I met you brother and run in
a time of oh yeah you met me as house
yeah we was gonna go Paris yeah we're
gonna go Paris yeah when we did go Paris
yes and you met me at his house yes
exactly that's what maybe I can remember
my she was very young
and I think if not your dad was well why
this guy my dad would ask me he that was
a bit later yes I don't think we keep
became close straightaway no but it was
like obviously yeah but my dad would ask
me why is this 27 however old you were
25 year old yeah yeah yeah because I
think we view it like you seen mature
that's good age you look mature and I
thought he seems betray as well but yeah
I think I then they it was you know it's
like people guarantee it shows you you
know it doesn't an age doesn't really
matter you know is this an even in
friendship you know like as long as on
the same level of course obviously I'm
not gonna stop watching with a 12 year
old or 13 year old Gigi I'm trying to
say from like 20 years old something
like that so we had did you ever
remember back our first ever argument we
had I don't think I don't think so
ah I think I do actually yeah I think I
did
you owe me to mention what was about do
you remember it no I think it was a
meadows house oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah so
basically
there was there was there was ally at
that time was newly practicing and I
wasn't I wasn't some so I didn't really
know I didn't know much myself
Yeah right but it's a thing where like
basically Ally wasn't married
he was newly practicing you you were
broke beginners like you you would make
like very basic mistakes if you were
just beginning broke yeah I remember
used to do this sometimes and be like
touch wood no no bro III didn't know its
initially but then I know it sounds like
bro why is that
why'd you keep doing that and then I
realized boy some like cool freaky thing
or something right but um that's what
I'm saying
we didn't know we were just young and we
just wanted to do something good you
know do some good deeds and self so I
remember you was online advising a
sister or brother yeah about their
marriage uh
in the DM so yeah and I think you were
saying like kya for you know you had
this very militant kind of mindset with
I think it's cause of your previous
experiences but you have this militant
mindset about guys and whatnot and what
they ought to do and I just said that
was a first argument officially and I'd
advise you and I said bro I don't think
you should do that because I don't think
you're in a position to do that yeah I
think with marriage it's a big thing
yeah and I don't think you should be
doing that and I should also show the
viewers something this is like a side
note but it's a very quick one that I'm
online
none of us are in a position where we
can just talk yeah you know we have
people that will put us up we will pull
each other up yeah Ali does something
I'll give him a phone call yeah you know
we do it with even with Mohammed hijab
like we talk to each other we have there
we were talking about this today yeah we
have these conversations amongst each
other and they get heated sometimes but
like at that time you got heated
basically I told you know another thing
you were having here and I took I'm
taking our event remand with the
marriage documentary I said I will talk
about but it was that was basically a
first one no what do you think they're
not people like waffle notice personally
is relation about my friendship with you
Mohammed II job different different
people in context and films I've
observed one thing that I see is people
easily and this is a big trait that
happens with marriage as well
we live in such comfort that we think
okay we treat borders we treat things as
materialistic objects so this if I don't
like this I'm gonna drink this if I
don't like this I'm gonna replace how
much I'm not having this again yeah yeah
so now what happens this is mentality we
carry it's a friendship and marriages
yeah this is a very big correlation yeah
okay this is one of the reasons I'm
developing my personal app which
inshallah with people of knowledge as
well because it'sit's a big problem this
is just friendship we're talking about
now when it comes to marriage is
marriage is where you've got kids
suffering you've got families you've got
and it's a family unit Islam is there to
show he is there to protect the family
unit that's what is so harsh against
adultery outside of marriage you get it
the punishment is so severe the
protective family unit and it was not
the consequences of people who haven't
had their father in their life the
mother in their life to get it so what
we do is we treat friendship and
marriage like that I don't like it I'll
replace it rough yeah I'll get rid of it
I'll get rid of it simple as that we do
this with everything food we eat the
clothes that we wear everything I don't
like tea I'll replace it now what
happens is with the friendship we apply
the same problems happening but nubra
you get it now before I came to Islam as
from the church community friendship is
seen as something strong okay something
where you call each other says there's a
word called conquer yeah it's like a
Miskin condition your condition that's
what it is shortened the yeah so conquer
means like my blood papa you're my blood
but even though you're not blood baba
but you say Kaddish you mean at some of
them actually we used to actually a
tremendous promise in the idea you would
cut yourself you cut your arm it's for
example let's say you cut yourself and
we'll join the blood together we'll be
conquered the shockwave blood brothers
it was something serum but now spawn
something now for yeah I think I did
that yeah and there might be a mark some
around here yeah this is quite
interesting but you see then the
friendship was strong like sometimes you
know you know you know you do wear
before your friend yeah yeah
the thing with when it came to Islam
with Islam it's greater than that but
you see I'm trying to say it's
Brotherhood now yeah this is Bravo this
is why for example not alia Salaam when
Allah stop ánotá when he said like save
me and my family
when his son when he was calling his son
and it's not in computed you do he said
all alike you said
you will save me in my family and Allah
you know what's that word rebuke the
prophet in a way where he said look if
you don't want to be amongst two losers
what was what do we learn from we
learned that your family is not the
people who are Chandra sinned against on
your family are the ones of Iman in real
in reality not explicitly said that is
exactly yes I mean he's not from your
family it's not Allah explicit he's
exactly and and because what and why
because Allah says in the Quran in surah
hood why why Allah give the reason is
well why is he he's not you from your
father
yeah in nomina later sorry that his
actions yeah right if I quoted the ayah
correctly his actions
well not righteous actions that's why
he's not from your family exactly so do
you see where Allah is telling us the
positive so it would be a bucket of
their disputes as well so one thing that
we think is that in friendship there's
gonna be no dispute we apply the same
thing in marriage
yeah and it fails well I did you
supposed to the the heated discussion
problems that we had some of them are
more peak which we're gonna come to but
one thing about coming to his a queue
sometimes we see friendship in Islam
which is Sadducees Muslims we don't
really treat it as friendship anything
the problem of you mr. Bundy
I never seen any good from him you know
this guy it start talking behind him
anything and how to be loved like first
your belief above backbiting is a
saintly okay sometimes you can get angry
okay we understand but the thing is to
dismiss somebody immediately bro I see
this trait with a lot of people yeah
person wasn't Muslims yet I seen this a
lot just easily disregard I never seen
interval from him finish good he's like
this anyways he's that anyways and
anything wow so all this time you've
been thinking like that here do do you
think dude you know see that I see a bro
I see it and I feel like bro it's a real
thing it's a real thing where it's like
if it wasn't for Islam I don't believe
even us we would be friends and I think
we're very close alhamdulillah like I
don't think I have another friend even
so my other close friends I don't have
this relationship with them where I can
just walk them into my house yeah it's
not like that even with them yeah I
think maybe you're one of the
only people I can do that with if
there's anyone else even it's not coming
to my head
honestly and I'm not just saying that
yeah so even with me I can say the same
to you I can say with you're the only
one that when I'm angry I will go full
out on you like a baby Bravo yeah and
that you might see that as right this
guy and I see as you know what
like my relationship review is so much
that I can go really and you do that
with me as well so this is the thing
there was a time where for bun this guy
yeah
but fingers now there was time out for
Bundy's guys yeah it was it was but the
thing is was a beautiful about Islam and
I think this is why this video is so
important what's beautiful about Islam
is that it teaches you to look past that
because a lot of people this is why a
lot of friendships they end yes
you see this well a lot of friendships
they end me and it's time also like
encourages you to end friendships for
the sake of Allah yes but the point is
that friendships when they're based on
this for the sake of Allah yeah the
little petty arguments that you have
with your friends which are not reasons
to end a friendship they keep your
friendship together for the sake of
Allah thing keeps your friendship
together and it makes it stronger and it
makes it more loyal and it makes it
that's wrong okay like say for the sake
of you for the sake of Allah is a
concept I never understood yeah the
first couple years of it neither did I
until the penny dropped because when you
love someone for the sake of Allah is
unconditional you try to make
unconditional because it was friendship
you can get stuff like you know it could
be like a form of you can have a triple
interest its base talking about you can
have a rib our friendship meaning you do
something okay I'll do this in return or
something did you get it it's like a
form of rebuttal your ear is and that
thing can also be feelings well exactly
exactly it doesn't need to be something
tangible or exactly but that's what it
can be the way mate someone makes you
feel and as soon as you stop feeling
like that yeah how lost you cut that
person exactly so when we talk about
loving for the sake of Allah you're
doing you're saying I am getting you
this for the sake of Allah I don't want
anything in return if you say thank you
to me know if you come to me later and
say you know what above you are the dirt
of this earth
I'll say you know what you know when I
bought you that well I have no regrets
I'm not gonna come and say you know
above I know we should ever know look
how ungrateful oh so you didn't do for
the sake of Allah it was you did
something and now because you have this
one less suppose you wrongs you if
you're doing it for the sake of Allah
you are not going to because something
comes in
bro you did this and this to this person
but look how he treated you I'll go okay
okay what's your point no no okay what's
your point I don't understand okay oh
you know what's its cause some people
like will come and say okay you know
what this person said this about you
okay what's your point brother listen
less of what he said okay he said that
all right okay father
if I've done what I've done for the sake
of Allah okey he can call me where if he
likes he can beat me up irrelevant so
that's why it's important for us to have
the and not dismiss each other okay you
know let me be friends with him because
I have some gain out you get it oh I
need him for this this is fake this is
not friendship let alone Brotherhood let
her know brother hidden Islam do have
Brotherhood keep it up Robert yeah yeah
because you know you have different
people are different I'm not talking me
I wanna see me mother here yeah
people have Brotherhood yeah but we're
talking about in Islam bro friends don't
do that let alone people that
Brotherhood yeah normos was a prophet
but in Islam you don't do that and I
think we should get rid of this habit if
we have a friend but you fell out was
not talked to seriously man first you
look is it that deep okay is it that
deep if it's not look overcome it me and
Musa we've had often down at this times
because the thing is I believe our
personality sometimes clash yeah and
that's something major but most people
in a marriage if that was like thing
talks it but I can't be around this
guide you get it but the thing is
there's ways of going about it
you get a wide you have to cut it from
the wreath you know there's ways about
going going about sometimes I do things
where I know it yeah it with you it just
like break and you can see above your
color your face you just flip and then
we need to when I see flip I'm like why
this kind of lip in an hour stuff have
been it was so much so that we had this
one three four five months ago in the
shuns house with the smart of Jenna's
house yeah and we had the black of big
life literally NACA that day I was I was
like no enough back well enough I notice
I'm not gonna talk to him
but see you know I'm gonna change my
stance with this guy yeah because I
think that this guy's taking the mick do
you get it like look at like I'm older
than him is well yeah now you have
forget friendship you respect me for
other things here I won in a bit I said
you know what not not only him I said
bear people I think is I blame myself so
you know what I think I'm being too kind
people taking my kind of these all stuff
for going for my head I send your audio
no and I said look you know what from
now on I never said I ended my
friendship I said look I'm gonna keep a
certain dollar ice
you get it but I can't because around
your colleges and the be myself he tried
to but he just can't but that was one
time with so much so that he son misses
me after you done that post on instead
we could go yeah we spoke to me as well
actually was you to know I told you I do
told me this is screenshot yeah you can
see it so he's like oh it's good you
guys patched up things yeah so in his
head he's thinking even me I was
thinking he's thinking five six months
ago and now we haven't spoken we didn't
we just made up now because the CC and
that's what the Broadway we we saw that
like a week or something like not even a
week yeah a day yeah yeah exactly we
said but we went home together yeah yeah
exactly
no that's one scene oh come on the way
home bro what other we had like I mean I
just said look let's agree to disagree
yeah by the way are so stand by what I
said yeah and no that's fine no this is
the thing right this is the thing
by the way our arguments are often not
over petty things it's not like yeah
yeah that's also another thing that I
think we should mention yeah I think
nearly every argument we've had either
has been about the devil yeah and that
shows something even that one was about
something that was a bit more a person
that was a bit person yeah but it was to
do with the Dean right yeah in a way
yeah for me yeah but but this is the
thing now I think I think what we need
to understand from from I don't if
you're gonna mention example so you
mention examples but like for example
there was a time where we were there was
the whole tummy Robinson thing going on
yeah
I've got very strong opinions about
things that happen online I don't agree
with certain things I don't agree with
being overtly focused on one individual
or one group and making your whole
YouTube channel about that and I'll say
it's even on your channel but this is
just me bro you gay like I don't
they even I was talking to you about
today about nother Braavos and bro we
need to chat him why is he focusing so
much on these people you gay yeah okay
boy well together and we chat to him bro
you gay like so but we love each other
fee and it's a genuine love bro when we
see to his love brought you gay
I know that you guys would that's how it
is bro yeah but our conversations about
the dollar I have very strong views so
like at that
time we were doing I was I was doing
Salaam as well right and Salaam was
different at that so it was a different
dynamic scream yeah so basically was he
job there no he was supposed to I think
I think he came after I came afterwards
he came off to it but basically what
happens is that it was me and you there
and III was I was setting up like a a
banner and our tent and stuff like that
in Marble Arch to for us to give Dawa
right so what happens is Ali
at that time was very focused on the
whole Tommy Robinson thing right which I
didn't agree with in the first place but
your dad said specifically stay like
leave them no yeah as in like because
because you had been going on them for a
long time now
yeah and I just have the mentality that
Hollis give you a Dawa [ __ ] you don't
need to cling on to people that was my
thing right now with you what happened
is some girl I didn't know who she is
yeah yeah she came and she started
picking she's got some big following as
well apparently you know what not and
she's from that that far right kind of
group yeah right she starts speaking to
you now and you went to speak to her
yeah no I don't know after that what
happened and I'll tell you why because
basically I just remember feeling Roger
was a I think I remember being really
angry like I remember I saw red that's
the only time that in my whole life
where I've been so angry because I the
cabrones disastrous treat like when
you're trying to give Dawa weird and is
these far-right guys coming and we're
just getting sidetracked that's how I
saw it right so I don't know why I said
to you I don't know what I'd done yeah I
think I said something to you yeah yeah
with me there like I was told like leave
these guys now cuz they're diverting
okay no problem but he just went off and
and the way I saw is I'm holding this it
was windy as to remember yeah I was
helping you what happened is I'm a
carrier very bootable sis and then
Lauren sovereign someone I was making
taught a lot to bring let me come across
this no Cigna I was saying oh she's
lying against them yet I'm carrying
water bows and then you who do I seem
from me know and soften and can I speak
to you I was like look I'm thinking in
my head yeah so far look at the time you
started
and these guys are telling me look and
leave them and I'm a cocky look from now
on I'm leaving it I'm not I'm leaving it
then she pops right in front of me and I
said look we're doing a campaign using
all of them so yeah no no no listen
I said come you can come and have a
bottle rule to the excess you can come
and you can come to us and I'm gonna be
the cuz I'm busy right now here cuz I
realize enough if they come I'll give
them some of these dates that we had or
some cookie thing try to break ice etc
and then when I realize didn't want to
talk I said look I said you saying look
bro you talk I said
Musa they came here they came I said if
you want it at least come because I'm
gonna talk to you guys enough so they
came and they talked etc and then they
went there and I said look I think I
spoke to your dad or something like that
there was a back foot I think he kind of
gave me permission or something that
others a current member he briefly said
look if you are go there or something
like that and then I don't think it was
there that I think I can go just me you
and me yeah yeah well yeah yeah I think
that came off the car member but anyway
I don't know what happened yeah but I
just knew I was like nah I'm never
talking to this guy we're just going to
announce that look bro this is craziness
like according to me yeah cuz a person's
mind works in a specific ways and have
certain things in their mind yeah I was
thinking this is Junoon this is madness
what are you doing yeah and I lost it
yeah didn't justify the way I lost it I
lost it completely and I was like that
well and even us alhamdulillah
there is never and this is one thing
that I have to mention both by the way
for benefit this is something I have to
mention for benefit yeah we've gotten
into it where we've see ice all red
because I remember I die you know when
these show in movies that people get
angry in this go red other we watch
movies in wonder but you know I'm giving
an example or in cartoons it goes red
bro I remember is that good I remember
blacking are you know looking at you
like this guy hey this guy has annoyed
me for so long about this year in Tamil
I'm going to you know yeah I don't know
what I said to you but one thing that I
will mention here not one of the
arguments we've had yeah in all of our
years of friendship where we've ever
become abusive to each other yeah who
ever sworn at each other yeah where
we've ever hit each other it's never
never not even swearing it yeah yeah
yeah and you correct me if I'm wrong
we've never done that yeah it's mining
Parisi
no it's not we've never limited by is
true yeah we we've never done and I just
thought about that now that wasn't a
plan point by the way I just remembered
that now and that that is because with
because I don't want the reason I
mention is some people may listen to
this anything oh oh it's normal what
happened to me my friends when we swear
at each other no no no no and this is
the thing I remember I spoke to one
brother in his marriage and he asked me
for advice a friend of mine and I said
to him don't swear up he's not no more
to say a man yeah yeah and he said it's
normal to swear both couples wait and I
said to him it's normal according to you
there's a practising brother cuz you've
made it normal yes I said you have the
same so strict on yourself where you
don't swear are your wife no you don't
swear even when you angry don't so at
the moment you swear respect it's going
down from there cuz if you can stop
calling each other names bro that means
the respect from there is down
alhamdulillah I I can and I don't think
it's a big deal to say it that's what
I'm gonna say it I don't swear I don't
swear . i don't it's not something in my
vocabulary exactly you don't swear I
know that cuz I've been around yeah yeah
so it's a thing we're like you you need
to understand that even though arguments
we're talking about uh aggressive one
for the Dawa yeah but they're also we're
not even abusing each other yeah but we
were just I think at that point in time
we just agreed that okay let's just yeah
no that was the let's just all man I was
the only moment where I say you know
what I'm not that's the heat of the
moment I said I'm not speaking now let
me ask you a question bro yeah I believe
I caused that argument yeah I believe I
caused it because with what I said oh
yeah one thing one thing that I really
like love about you as a friend is that
when you acknowledge your mistake you
say it this one thing that I've realized
and this is one thing I can say is a key
to successful marriage and friendship is
that you don't have this ego it's that
look you know what bro you call and be
that you know I was wrong you have
moments where you shine like it's Rama's
shine I'm not saying you know shine
bright like a diamond I'm talking about
shine now you're mad you lose it yeah
but then you have your moments you just
calm down and then and then you say bro
if I have do you get it and I think
that's so fundamental
bro you have to and
you know in your relationship with
marriage with friendship with
Brotherhood sisterhood you have to drop
the ego yes laughter you can't have an
ego you know and this isn't Subhan Allah
this is an Islamic concept one for two
this books you can read on this but
non-muslims yeah you know like her
what's his name
Ryan holiday wrote a book called ego is
the enemy the tireless ego is the enemy
yeah so book about how egos gonna mess
you up yeah you have egos gonna mess you
up yeah yeah and and and the thing is
from an Islamic perspective yeah ego is
not a good thing so in your
relationships it's like a short drive
anyway but like ego yeah is an is an
enemy of yours yes yeah so what you have
to understand is that in your
relationships you can't have ego you're
not only one of the things that gets to
me is when people treat Islam like like
a theoretical thing yeah
and I've seen this in a lot of people
may Allah protect us from it people
treat Islam like something or theory so
when they actually in a situation and
they know Islam says they won't act by
it they want yeah
you'll be like but I'm like Islam is for
that situation
do you understand yeah like it's Aslam
isn't like for example when the Prophet
settlers on senem spoke about arrogance
or you know or spoke about bad traits of
people jealousy has said he's not
speaking about that in ideal situations
it's it's in situations that maybe can
get rough there don't have arrogance or
when when allah says in the quran way by
doraemon in Laveen am Shannara love the
ho no una GG Haruna Alou Salama when
Allah says when die Abbado Rahman I'm
sort of work on one of the traits of the
slaves of Rahman is that what is the hot
tub of homogeny Luna Colusa Lama when
someone comes to them with jahiliya
with ignorance swearing at you abusing
you etc or do they say i loo salaam and
they say salaam now someone may come and
say okay i was angry okay you have to
understand bro i reacted like this of
course I had to swear at you are he was
doing that to me of course I have to
yeah bro that's not Islam yeah Islam is
where the hot tub of Mujahid una cosa
lama when someone comes to jahiliyyah
okay fellows may Allah bless you sir
harmonica and
a genuine place and then you leave it
exactly yeah that's that's fine that's
how is that people are idealistic broad
they think that these situations are for
ideal no no man that of course not you
know a list ik this this happen with you
know the best of people and to be honest
with me like even there's some people
are gonna be like there's some people no
we speak to people they think that we
don't speak to which we have kind of in
the public safes fearful mouth yeah yeah
we speak I'll be honest with us P people
think if I see some people that that we
have disagreement well yeah that we
believe should repent for some games
yeah that we believe these things but
people think if we see them on the
street on site yeah yeah we're it's not
like that bro we're not gangsters bro
like with it's like we'll say Salaam
some money come on here how are you okay
will speak lies you know some people
with me it's it will take a look you
have to do something major personally to
me for me to speak to you most of the
times are falling that was certain my
brothers is because of the injustice
that I believe they have made others
suffer I think this is it personally for
me it's that look it's nothing you've
done it done to me because if I look at
this Bob is mashallah that they've done
a lot for me my personal actually I'm
trying to say and I will testify to
Allah and I make to offer them but it's
the injustice which they've done to
others maybe not even intentionally but
when I see that is that when I've done
that you see I'm trying to say so that's
it man I don't know is anything else is
anything less ender on this was anything
that you would change one thing about me
if there's one thing you change about me
besides my looks come on my wife first
of all no second in your friend yeah
there's nothing I would change about you
oh I don't think I'd change anything
about you
I wouldn't change anything by you
because it's fine bro you gay like I
accept you for full for the problematic
person that you are I wouldn't change
anything about you brought I think
you're very genuine person I'm not just
saying that because you're here bunch of
I think that you haven't changed with
your online persona that really happened
and I hope that you don't I hope that
you know that I don't care if you've got
four hundred thousand subscribers I
couldn't I couldn't care said I'll get
Musa
honestly and we've had like cuz look and
I think that that's maybe I don't know
if it makes you realize this but maybe
that makes you think of me as genuine as
well because some friends are gay they
hang around people they want to get
close to people which is something I
don't understand
to benefit from them yeah yeah that's
what I said in the amount of people that
we've met even being in the Dawa yeah
well financially mashallah well-off and
whatnot yeah bro we could literally like
be their best friends just for the sake
of money but that's that's that's how it
needs to be bowl of the fingers you need
to understand you have to be real with
yourself
yeah with me there's been people in my
life where like bro like they have so
much to offer like in the context across
a multitude of them don't ya bro monitor
yeah that I have said you know what Baba
I'm so sorry I'm seeing what I'm gaining
here and one about to lose but if I'm
gonna look at myself in the mirror and
be like you didn't speak are getting
this injustice because of this one how
can I live with myself how fake can you
be that I'm gonna turn a blind eye to an
oppression because I have money to
regain from here sorry
so the thing this Brahmin sisters be
real to yourself don't be fake what like
a nun with your friends be said let me
tell you something Allah has a Sunnah
physical laws karate that's a physical
law there's metaphysical laws I was put
in place yeah there is metaphysical laws
or laws put in place you see this
gravity there's metaphysical laws if you
apply them one line you be successful
what like I don't believe me I've seen
it of a private and I haven't lost
anything I haven't lost anything here so
it's very important prom ancestors for
us to acknowledge that and have true
friendship if you're having a friendship
what why he and you're using somebody
you're just fooling yourself well I
should tell you cuz you know Allah soon
I will apply the metaphysical law you're
using them you'll be only to your
detriment you'll be too detriment look
at that person wouldn't lose anything
anything that you do you know Allah says
in the Quran this is the last thing I'll
say yeah yeah you and levena a menudo
hulu Fissel McGuffy well atta boy photo
autoshare funny in the lucuma do human
being very famous ayah you might may
heroin Jamal's right Allah says yeah you
and levena almond or you who believe oh
do Hulu facility uh enter into
submission
completely kafir completely
come along not say 90% completely while
at the table hoto a t-shape on in Naju
lucuma duma bean and don't follow the
footsteps of Shaitan he is to you a
clear enemy right there's a book that
I'm reading and in it the author
mentions that if you enter into
submission 90% you will harm yourself if
you enter insert into submission
95% you will harm yourself 99 percent
this is the point that is expressed in
the book right 99 percent you will harm
yourself you have to do Hulu Fissel me
kaffir that's it you have to enter
completely what that means is with your
relationships they need to be for the
sake of Allah yeah and and you'll see
this bro looking in terms of your life
are you in complete submission in all of
your life in the areas where you're not
you're suffering and you'll say yourself
if you're wrong in yourself if you're
running a large loss you haven't entered
in submission complete part of a las
laws is that you need to do things for
his sake you need to be in friendships
for his sake you'd need to not be in
friendships for the sake of other form
for monetary things if you're doing that
then there's not gonna be blessings I
wouldn't and that's how only people
who've been friends for sorry one knows
it they've been friends for 10 years are
he and they stopped 10 years 15 years
they've been friends for and they stop
and they don't talk to each other ever
again you know and this is a problem you
need to be friends for the sake of Allah
and what is that what is Allah saying of
Quran welliton so we'll fodhla been
Akuma
don't forget the fuddle between you
don't forget the virtue that you had
between that's very interesting
it's a beautiful I imagined it to you
the other day yeah this is about the
Monday crosses o stodgy mouth which I'm
personally dedicated I'm taking Monday's
off obviously we were quarantine so
they've been off yeah but in here let me
tell you how he explained it yeah I was
blown away I was like please just a
little bit the favors so one of the
things that we've learned from our
teacher is that you should use the Quran
as Maxim's in your life don't just read
the Quran and put on the Shelf memorize
potts portions of the Quran even if
you're not gonna do all of it you should
have the goal to memorize all of it but
like memorize portions and just use them
as Maxim so this is one portion on
memorizing welliton so hablaba know come
if I have a problem with you now I
should
remember that don't remember the virtue
that you had between you and Ally apply
it to yourself
Dorman don't forget the virtue don't
forget the good times don't forget when
you went on holiday together in Dubai I
remember that to this day that holiday
we went in Dubai how beautiful was how
nice it was so yeah basically that's so
that's what happens when any kind of
fall that happens what we do is we
automatically go to all the negative
things and if you think about the good
outweighs the bad
yeah but we pick on okay no he did this
he did that is it worth this missing
somewhere and your friendship just
because of one thing that they that they
did and you need autism is that person
intention doing it to hurt you if you're
a friend look seriously to ask yourself
a question
okay he did something to hurt me if that
is intentional
then you need to question okay look why
you doing something to hurt me is it
intentional if this your friend it
shouldn't be intentional yeah so you
need to speak and communication is key
should I tell you something
another issue that destroys marriages
and friendships is what's up well I have
seen so many argument oh I thought you
meant like this yeah I don't know that
any bro and trust me I don't do speak on
the phone I was having a conversation
with someone the other day and I just
could you don't do that that's no no no
but I'm telling you speak on in person
that's it yeah that's it hey I was just
gonna say one last thing yeah which is
that Allah says in the Quran about our
people on your mother qiyamah
yeah they will be to each other enemies
yeah there will be to each other enemy
and Allah makes a distinction he says
except then what the kun yeah the
god-conscious yeah so that shows you
that everyone's gonna be enemies to each
other you're gonna be my enemy if this
isn't if we aren't good conscious so we
need to be good conscious we need to
have stuck or and part of having taqwa
of course would be to be to do things
for the sake of Allah so do your
friendships with us for the sake of
Allah bless you guys benefit from this
it's a lie and if you've got friends
that you fill out with makeup initially
yeah that's a good it's important poem
yes well you should make up watch this
video together insha'Allah it's not that
deep inshallah and try your best and
love each other for save all those
pounds Allah may Allah keep our
friendship with our friends strong in
this life and the hereafter bonuses
insha'Allah and
may Allah inshallah unites engender
together that is the real aim and
objective of what we do near San Juanico
a better care to if you liked this video
one similar videos anything to do with
that real talk about that comment my
just carry on doing it you never know
you do again from the bye